Garde à vous !
Soldats ! La forêt derrière vous est l'un des terrains minés les plus dangereux de ce siècle
C'est Internet !
Notre mission est très simple, faire une blague sur internet.
Beaucoup ont essayé, très peu en sont revenus vivants.
Religion, ethnie
Homosexualité, féminisme, politique
Ces sujets sont très sensibles.
Vaut mieux pas s'y aventurer.
- Mais si la blague est subtile et bien faite sergent ?!
- Tu veux faire le malin soldat ?!
Je t'en prie, fais ta blague
- Les femmes, mettent du temps à se préparer dans la salle de bain parce que... *Boum*
- On vient de perdre l'un de nos hommes pour une blague misogyne !
Cheh !
Explosifs, snipers isolés
Mine anti-personnel, barbelé, grenade
Et parfois même, embuscade !
Faites attention à tout ce que vous dites ici !
- Sergent ! On peut même pas faire une simple blague sur les nains ? *Tir raté dans le casque*
- On dit pas nains ! On dit personnes de petite taille.
Tu viens de te prendre une balle de Twittos, du 33 RT en plus !
Bref,
Ne plaisantez pas avec ces sujets sur Internet ou vous finirez comme lui.
- Mais sergent, pourtant certains y arrivent !
Plaisanter avec des choses aussi sensibles ça s'est déjà vu non ?
- Ouais, mais ce ne sont pas des soldats, soldat !
Ce sont des légendes.
Allez suivez-moi !
- Wouah ça ne donne pas envie Internet, hein !
Toute cette méchanceté gratuite !
- Ouais
Mais dire un truc sur Internet ou même faire une simple blague
C'est notre mission !
- C'est qui eux ?
- Eux anciennement on les appelait l'Armée Rouge.
Enfin... Les pouces rouges.
Et la légende raconte que certains d'entre eux sont des enfants soldats...
- Je l'ai eu, pouce en bas
- LES ENFANTS À TABLE ! - On arrive maman !
- Oh mon dieu !
C'est horrible
- C'est Toto, il est enfermé aux toilettes...
Et ça frappe à la porte, - Pu***n, mais c'est qui ce mec !
Il fait une blague de merde, Il y a aucune mine qui explose on lui tire même pas dessus pu***n !
- C'est normal, il a la médaille de la hype.
Sauf que la hype ne dure qu'un temps désormais les gens l'ont déjà oublié
Il est fini à tout jamais.
- Heu...Excusez-moi !!!
Hey les mecs !
Dites je peux rejoindre votre armée ? Parce qu'en fait je suis tout seul et j'aimerais...
- Mais en fait le problème c'est...
- Ne réponds pas, il s'est pris un obus à Badbuzz pour des propos sexistes.
Il pourrait tous nous contaminer, pas de RT, pas de Tag, pas de mention.
Surtout pas toi ! Dieu sait que t'aimes ça !
- C'est bon les gars, là j'arrête tout ! C'est bon ça m'a saoulé !
Là je vais dans le Nord c'est beaucoup plus safe (sécurisé), y a pas de mines, pas de barbelé.
C'est bon c'est fini. - Mais où elle va ?
- Nom de dieu, elle va dans la zone des podcasts.
La raclette, faire les courses tout ça...
C'est une zone safe mais au bout d'un moment on s'y fait un peu chier
- C'est vrai que c'est bien de la merde hein quand même...
- Ouais bon des fois j'y suis un peu allé dans ma carrière on va pas se mentir...
Let's Go ! (C'est parti) C'est le front qui nous attend Mother Fu***r !
Ici, on arrive au cœur du champ de bataille,
Les rageux pourraient nous tomber dessus à chaque instant ... fais gaffe à toi.
- Ok je me mets en mode camouflage alors.
- C'est trop calme,
J'aime pas trop beaucoup ça...
- Bon, si c'est calme, tant mieux, on n'a rien à craindre.
- OH MON DIEU, tu viens de faire une black face, l'un des sujet les plus explosifs, on va tous mourir !
Efface-moi ça tout de suite !
- Nan mais je savais pas ! - Attention, un bombardement de mauvais commentaires !
- Au secours, aidez-moi s'il vous plaît ! - Oh regardez sergent, un civil, on dirait qu'il a besoin d'aide
- Moi je suis juste venu
sur les réseaux sociaux pour rire un peu
et maintenant je suis coincé ici !
- Mais sergent il faut l'aider !
- Non, non soldat,
C'est au dessus de mes forces...
Faire rire dans un tel climat de haine,
d'animosité
et d'injures gratuites,
c'est trop pour moi.
j'pose les armes...
j'en ai plus rien à foutre de cette guerre.
- Mais bordel sergent, c'est pas le moment de se dégonfler okay !
Vous voyez le civil là-bas ! Il a juste envie de rire vous comprenez ?! Rire !
Il s'en fout des attaques sociales ! hein !
Vous pensez tellement à vos ennemis que vous pensez plus à votre vraie mission !
Faire une blague sur internet !
Une simple blague OK !!!
Vous imaginez si tout le monde pensait comme vous !
Plus de créativité, plus d'humour, c'est ça que vous voulez ?
Je pense pas hein.
Donc ce qu'on va faire, on va aller voir ce civil,
on va le mettre sur un brancard
et on va lui faire une blague de merde !
Oui j'ai dit merde !! Oui j'ai dit merde et alors !!
J'ai dit vulgarité et je vous emmerde, tous !!!
Sergent on y va ! Tout de suite !
1, 2, 3 !
Alors c'est l'histoire d'un belge, d'un juif et de Bob l'éponge...
Et là, y a Chuck Norris qui sort, en femme, parce qu'il a changé de sexe !
*fou rire*
Wow !
Donald Trump répond "quoi moi je suis pas chaud"
*fou rire*
Il a osé !
Alors là, battle de twerk générale !
*fou rire*
Et une fois que la Terre a explosée, c'est là que Bob l'éponge dit :
Bah, c'était pas une algue ! C'était ma femme !
Euh... par contre la chute elle était pas ouf
Ouais c'était pas ouf mais euh... GO !
En tout cas maintenant, cette bataille est derrière nous !
Merci ! Vous m'avez sauvé de toute cette haine !
Bravo Sergent !
Bravo à vous, Soldat !
En plus d'après mes calculs, ici on est dans la zone des allégories.
Par exemple l'allégorie de comparer Internet à un terrain miné.
En gros ici c'est ultra safe, on a plus rien à craindre.
- Vous êtes sûr là ? Parce que ça fait "Bip Bip" sous nos pieds là.
Messieurs, va falloir être forts.
On vient de gagner une bataille, mais on est bien loin d'avoir gagné la guerre.
Soldat, pour t'engager dans ma chaîne youtube, clique sur ma tête et abonne-toi !
Nous avons besoin de gens comme vous. Courageux, vifs, qui ont soif d'aventure, et qui ont la peau douce !
Et qui se lavent avec un savon hypoallergénique, c'est la base